Vamos a hablar - de mi - nueva conferencia, sólo
para TED. Les voy a mostrar algunas ilusiones
que he creado para TED y voy a tratar de
relacionar esto con la felicidad. Lo que pensaba
sobre la felicidad es: ¿qué brinda felicidad?
O felicidad, que yo igualo a júbilo en mi
área en particular, y pienso que hay algo
fundamental. Y estaba pensando en esto.
Es que hablando tanto de ilusiones como de películas
que vemos, como las bromas y funciones de magia,
todos tienen algo que rompen con
nuestras expectativas en una cierta
forma agradable. Cuando van a ver una película
y tiene un giro, algo que no esperan, encuentran
que es una experiencia feliz. En mi libro ven
este tipo de ilusiones y no es lo
que esperaban, pero hay algo feliz en ello.
Lo mismo ocurre con las bromas y en todo este
tipo de cosas. Entonces, lo que voy a tratar de
hacer en mi conferencia es ir un poco más allá
y ver si puedo romper sus expectativas de manera
agradable. Me explico, en ocasiones es desagradable
romper las expectativas, pero lo voy a intentar
hacer de manera agradable, de una forma primitiva,
tal que pueda hacer feliz a la audiencia aquí.
Entonces les voy a mostrar algunas maneras como
podemos romper sus expectativas. Antes que nada,
les quiero mostrar una ilusión en particular aquí.
Quiero antes que nada que cuando aparezca en la pantalla
noten que hay dos hoyos perpendiculares entre sí,
Estos son todos trucos de percepción.
Todos los objetos que les voy a enseñar son reales.
Ahora les voy a enseñar cómo se hace.
Avanzo la película aquí tal que puedan tener una
experiencia interesante. Quiero que vean como esta hecha
esta ilusión. Va a rotar para que vean que está
del interior hacia fuera. Ahora observen, conforme
gira de regreso, lo repentino que su percepción cambia. Bien.
Observen cuando gira otra vez. Ustedes son una audiencia muy
brillante ¿de acuerdo? Vean si pueden evitar que
ocurra, aun cuando saben al 100%
la verdad es que ¡bum! No lo pueden enmendar.
¿Qué les dice esto acerca de ustedes? Lo vamos a
hacer otra vez. Sin duda. Vean si pueden evitar
que ocurra. No. Es difícil.
Podemos romper sus expectativas en toda una
variedad de formas ya sea en la representación,
la forma, el color y demás. Y es muy primitivo.
Es una pregunta interesante a considerar,
¿por qué nos divierten estas cosas? ¿Por qué las encontramos
divertidas? Entonces, aquí hay algo que
Lionel hizo hace un buen rato. Me gustan este
tipo de cositas.
Otra vez, este no es un truco óptico. Esto es lo
que verán. En otras palabras, no es un truco de
cámara. Es un truco de percepción.
Ok. Podemos romper sus expectativas
sobre la forma.
Podemos romper sus expectativas en la representación,
en lo que una imagen representa, ¿qué ven aquí?
¿Cuántos de ustedes ven los delfines? Levanten la mano
si ven los delfines. Bien, aquellos que levantaron
la mano, después diríjansen con el resto de la
audiencia ¿de acuerdo? En realidad, este es el
mejor ejemplo de experiencia primitiva que conozco.
Si eres un niño menor de 10 que no has sido
estropeado todavía, verás esta imagen y
verás delfines. Ahora bien, algunos de ustedes adultos
se estarán diciendo: "¿Delfines? ¿Cuáles delfines?"
Pero de hecho, si invertimos el fondo de la imagen,
en otras palabras, las áreas oscuras aquí – olvidé
pedir un apuntador – pero si lo invierten, verán
toda una serie de pequeños delfines. Por cierto,
si también son estudiantes de CalTech, también
tenderán a sólo ver los delfines. Esto se basa
en la experiencia.
Ahora, algo como esto se puede usar porque a fin de
cuentas esta es también una charla sobre diseño. Bien,
esto lo hicieron Saatchi y Saatchi y es más, se salieron
con la suya con este anuncio en Australia.
Si miran el anuncio de cerveza, todas estas personas
tienen posturas provocadoras. Se los aprobaron y hasta
ganaron premios Clio, así que es divertido
hacer estas cosas.
Recuerdan esta clase de, mm. Esta es la broma que hice
cuando estaba pasando la votación en Florida.
Cuenten los puntos para Gore, cuenten los puntos para
Bush. Cuéntelos otra vez.
Pueden romper sus expectativas de la
experiencia. Aquí hay una fuente exterior que
hicimos unos amigos míos y yo, en la que pueden parar
el agua en gotas y de hecho hacer que todas
las gotas leviten. Esto es algo que construimos
para parques de diversiones y cosas
por el estilo.
Ahora vayamos a una imagen estática ¿pueden ver esto?
¿Ven la sección intermedia moverse hacia abajo y las
secciones exteriores moverse para arriba? Están completamente estáticas.
Es una imagen estática ¿cuántas personas ven esta
ilusión? Es completamente estática.
Bien. Ahora cuando… es interesante que cuando miramos
una imagen, vemos color, profundidad, textura.
Pueden ver la escena completa y
analizarla. Pueden ver a la mujer más cerca que
la pared, etcétera. Pero todo el conjunto es
en realidad plano. Está pintado. Es lo que se llama trampantojo.
Y es tan buen ejemplo de trampantojo que la gente
se irritaba cuando tratan de hablar con la
mujer y que no les respondía.
Ahora bien, pueden hacer errores de diseño. Como
este edificio en Nueva York. De modo que si lo ven de
este lado, parece que las balcones se ladean hacia arriba,
y cuando caminan hacia el otro lado parece
que los balcones se ladean hacia abajo. Así que hay
casos donde hay errores de diseño que
incorporan ilusiones.
O, tomen esta fotografía en particular sin
retocar. Resulta muy interesante que recibo muchos
correos de gente que dice: ¿existe alguna diferencia
de percepción entre hombres y mujeres?
Y en realidad digo: “No”. Quiero decir, las mujeres pueden
navegar el mundo tan bien como los hombres pueden ¿por qué
no podrían hacerlo? Sin embargo, esta es una
ilusión en la que las mujeres consistentemente
sobresalen a los hombres al aparear la cabeza
porque cuentan con pistas de moda. Ven si el sombrero coordina.
Ok, yendo a la parte de… quiero mostrar
diseño de ilusiones. Creo que el primer
ejemplo de ilusiones que fue usado con un propósito fue
esta imagen anafórmica de un ojo por da Vinci.
Cuando miran desde un pequeño ángulo es como esto.
Y esta pequeña técnica se hizo popular en el
siglo 16 y 17 para esconder mensajes
en los que se podía girar la imagen
y verla desde este pequeño punto de vista de esta forma.
Pues estas son inclusiones tempranas de ilusiones
traídas por… una especie de tema álgido con
“Embajadores” de Hans Holbein. Hans Holbein trabajaba
para Enrique VIII. Esto estaba colgado en una pared donde
si uno bajaba de la escalera podía ver
esta calavera escondida.
Muy bien. Ahora voy a mostrarles algunos
diseñadores que trabajaron con ilusiones que dan
ese elemento de sorpresa. Uno de mis favoritos es Scott Kim.
Trabajé con Scott para crear algunas ilusiones
para TED y espero que las disfruten. Tenemos una
aquí en TED y felicidad.
Ok ahora. Arthur [Ganson] todavía no da su charla,
que será una delicia y tiene algunas de sus
máquinas realmente fantásticas afuera. Entonces, nosotros
con Scott creamos este maravilloso tributo a Arthur
Ganson.
Bien, tenemos análogo y digital. Pensamos
que esto era apropiado.
Y la figura cambia al fondo.
Y para los músicos.
Y por supuesto, puesto que la felicidad, queremos
"alegría en el mundo".
Ahora, otro gran diseñador, muy conocido
en Japón es Shigeo Fukuda. Él sencillamente
construye algunas cosas fantásticas. Esto es
sencillamente asombroso. Esto es una pila de deshechos que
cuando los ven desde un ángulo en particular, ven
reflejando en el espejo un piano perfecto.
El pianista que se transforma en violinista.
Esto es realmente de locura. Este montaje de tenedores,
cuchillos y cucharas y cubiertos, soldados entre sí
nos dan la sombra de una motocicleta.
Lo que se aprende en el tipo de cosas que hago,
es que hay mucha gente por ahí con
mucho tiempo en sus manos.
Ken Knowlton hace imágenes compuestas maravillosas.
Como creando a Jacques Cousteau de conchas marinas,
conchas sin retocar, únicamente acomodadas.
Hizo a Einsten de dados porque, después de todo,
fue Einstein quien dijo que "Dios no juega a los
dados con el universo". Bert Herzog hecho de teclados
sin retocar. Will Shortz de crucigramas.
John Cederquist hace estos maravillos
trampantojos con gabinetes.
Ahora me voy a adelantar porque como que me estoy
atrasando. Quiero mostrales rápidamente lo que he
creado. Un nuevo tipo de ilusiones. He estado
haciendo cosas como ilusiones del tipo Pixar.
Ven a estos niños del mismo tamaño aquí, corriendo
por el pasillo. Las dos mesas son del mismo tamaño.
Están mirando en dos direcciones al mismo tiempo.
Aquí tienen una pieza grande que cabe en una más pequeña.
Y esto es algo en qué pensar ¿están de acuerdo?
Como ven las piezas grandes caben dentro de las piezas
más chicas aquí ¿ven esto todos?
Lo cual es imposible. Pueden ver a los dos niños
mirando simultáneamente hacia dos direcciones
diferentes al mismo tiempo. Ahora bien ¿pueden creer que
estas dos mesas son iguales en tamaño y forma? Lo son.
Si los miden, lo verán. Como dije, estas dos
figuras son idénticas en tamaño y forma.
Es interesante que al hacer esta clase de
formas de representaciones, cómo las ilusiones
son más fuertes. Cual sea el caso, espero que esto
les haya dado un poco de alegría y felicidad.
Si les interesa ver más efectos fabulosos, estaré
afuera y con mucho gusto les mostraré muchas cosas más.